a simple shopping expedition is no
longer a pleasant pastime for Iranians
it's not only the prices for imported
goods which have shot up since the US
re-imposed sanctions paralyzing Iran's
foreign trade prices for groceries and
other basics are also skyrocketing the
country's currency the real is also
depreciating rapidly those lucky enough
to have access to dollars or Euros are
best off into Iran's Grand Bazaar the
anger is palpable if the situation
remains like this we'll have to leave
your own we're trying very hard to get
out of the country definitely there's no
future here as you can see Iran ian's
need bread rather than nuclear programs
they want their economic situation to
improve the point is that you can't fill
up your kids bellies with nuclear energy
the new US sanctions also make it
practically impossible for German
companies to do business with Iran
firstly because hardly any banks are
willing to handle the payments leaving
the Iranians with no way to pay the
invoices and also because Washington has
threatened retribution against any
companies which continued to do business
with Tehran funding field on the name
out of the many companies which set out
to rekindle their old business
relationships as soon as EU sanctions
against Iran were repealed only 60 are
left and they're more or less just
keeping an eye on the situation on the
ground rather than actually doing any
business there tomorrow companies like
multi vac a German mid-sized company and
global leader in food packaging during
previous sanctions it was still able to
offer maintenance services to its
Iranian clients to keep their often
decades-old machinery running but this
time around not even that much is
possible
any activity in Iran could cause
incalculable damage to multi vak
elsewhere
cut off from the outside world with
rampant inflation and unemployment
rising the lives of ordinary Iranians
become harder by the day
Adnan Tabata why is director of the
think-tank Abu Adnan say we get to
Sunday Anna runs deadlines forgetting
the u.s. to ease sanctions passes what
can we expect what we will have to
expect is that Iran means business that
means that they will exceed the limit of
three point six seven percent grade of
enriched uranium and this will certainly
further complicate the whole discussion
about the nuclear agreement or the jcpoa
and we have to expect that a whole new
wave of playing game between Iran Europe
and the US will on second now the
sanctions have been in place for months
you were just there what impact did you
see all the people you can see immediate
impacts that that food prices as we have
seen in your report are going up any
goods that are imported from the outside
the prices are spiking we can see me and
long term long term effects in the way
that people are losing confidence in in
the future there is a lot of uncertainty
as as to where the economy of this
country is is going to and and that
uncertainty is really hard for people to
to suggest so so just how badly has the
economy being hip would you say I mean
the Iranian economy has not really been
in good shape anyways before that but
the sanctions the new sanctions regime
certainly exacerbating that economic
malaise so we have corruption and
mismanagement that has been there before
and sanctions are just making it even
even worse than that there is all no
sense of the collapse of the economy but
at least there is a lot of hardship now
just lastly Trump's strategy is to use
these sanctions to turn the Iranians
against the government that's his
strategy is it working
that is certainly not working for a
couple of reasons first because the
Iranians are realizing that it's not
just their own government that can be
blamed for production mismanagement but
also the outside world namely the US for
the sanctions secondly people who live
under economic hardship we don't have
the time for political activities or to
be active in any sort of movement they
have to make their needs they have to
try to meet the needs of their everyday
lives so they're much more busy with
these questions and the Iranian
establishment has been always take a
beloved eating those who are in most
leaves so we cannot really expect that
the people will turn against the
government there but certainly the
hardship is felt and the two sides are
linked their own government as well as
the US nan Tabata by director of the
think-tank
Capo on those sanctions and how they're
hitting the Iranian economy thank you
very much for joining us